[Música]
Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en France 24 Hola
cómo están Argentina es un país visto
como desarrollado como el país más
europeo tal vez de América Latina pero
la gente no conoce tanto esta parte más
rural que tú relatas en tus libros crees
que el resto del mundo tiene tal vez una
visión un poquito distorsionada de
Argentina sí creo que Esa visión de país
europeo quizás se corresponde más con
Buenos Aires
entonces
a veces lo que pasa Eso es eso que para
los extranjeros Argentina es solamente
Buenos Aires Y
sí creo que bueno es un país muy grande
y muy poco Federal Entonces sí es verdad
que incluso nosotros mismos no tenemos
mucho registro de
de cómo son otras regiones del país o
que cada una tiene su particularidad su
modo de hablar su música y a veces es
verdad que eso queda un poco siempre
como como encapsulado en cada región y
no hay mucha circulación de toda esa
cultura musical literatura
artistas visuales
no hay una circulación muy integral
y Tu última novela no es un río si eres
un ciclo llamado la trilogía de los
varones pero de manera general trabajas
mucho con personajes masculinos cierto
de dónde vienen esas ganas de analizar
entrar dentro del corazón de los hombres
y contar el impacto que ellos tienen en
sus propios ámbitos
en realidad se fue como medio
[Música]
accidental o involuntario
y que se armara esta que después yo
llamé trilogía de varones porque el
primer libro que es el viento Carranza
me acuerdo que cuando yo empecé a
escribirlo la protagonista iba a ser la
hija y Incluso el título provisorio de
la novela era la hija y después de
repente los personajes masculinos
empezaron a adquirir más protagonismo y
bueno Y así se dio en esa novela en la
segunda que es ladrillero sí había como
O sea estaba esta historia entre dos
varones una historia amorosa erótica y Y
si empezó a aparecer más claramente esto
de indagar en los vínculos entre los
varones
y ya fue su mucho más consciente
y también la violencia tiene un rol
central en tu obra porque tiene tanto
peso sería un síntoma de Estos espacios
que exploras primero creo que es
narrativamente Me parece muy poderoso
narrar la violencia y después si es como
Bueno una parte de estos universos que
me gusta abordar en las novelas en
general bueno estos personajes
masculinos son tipos violentos machistas
borrachos peleas peleadores
son hombres del trabajo físico
y bueno en grupos así
la violencia se hace más evidente que en
otros que quizás en otros grupos o
clases sociales donde existe Por
supuesto que también existe la violencia
Pero quizá de una de otra bueno tiene
otra forma
yo sentí que habían patrones que se
repiten en tus novelas no solo en las
escenografías Rurales sino también en
las consecuencias de estos ámbitos que
son la impunidad la violencia lo hemos
hablado la ineficaz de la justicia crees
que estos lugares sufren algún tipo de
maldición que condena una mayoría de las
personas a no salir nunca de ahí a
repetir siempre los mismos errores
bueno no lo llamaría maldición Porque
esa sería llevar una problemática social
cultural económica
estructural del país a un plano
más fantástico O esotérico creo que la
desigualdad o sea justamente en esto en
un país tan grande Argentina la
desigualdad también es muy grande y se
ha acrecentado en las últimas décadas y
entonces
buena parte de la población no tiene
opciones no
de repente la única opción es emigrar
para buscar trabajo a grandes ciudades
como Buenos Aires o Rosario Córdoba y
después esas ciudades se saturan de
gente y ya tampoco hay trabajo y no hay
donde vivir y creo que tiene más que ver
con con la situación de un país sería
Tal vez un más bien un círculo vicioso
que encierra un poquito las personas sí
creo que es bueno consecuencia de de un
de problemas que económicos y sociales y
culturales y de Educación que venimos
arrastrando desde la dictadura hasta
hasta hoy digo pasando por el menemismo
en los
una gran parte de la población no solo
en la pobreza sino la falta de acceso a
cuestiones básicas como la salud y la
educación Pero tú te fuiste de donde de
donde vienes
creciste en un pueblo chiquito de Entre
Ríos que está esta provincia que está
pegada a Uruguay bastante cerca al final
de Buenos Aires donde vives donde vives
ahora
y yo escuché en unas entrevistas que
cuentas que haya no te sentías también
con las normas
las reglas conservadoras de este lugar y
que por eso te fuiste bastante joven
escribir sobre la provincia sería una
manera de entender la mejor tal vez
reconciliarte un poquito con ella
no es que tampoco me haya ido peleada
sí sí probablemente volver a esos este
espacios y a los que igual vuelvo
también físicamente y en la realidad
Porque mi familia sigue viviendo allí o
sea que no es un lugar que yo visito
frecuentemente
pero pero sí quizá
la escritura o volver en aflicción en
estos lugares puede ser que sea una una
manera de intentar comprender mejor lo
que como se arman esos vínculos y esas
tramas en en estos lugares más pequeños
y más alejados de ciudades más grandes y
con más posibilidades
hay mucha oralidad en tus novelas juegas
mucho con el con el decir con la manera
de hablar con el sólido Incluso el ritmo
de las conversaciones como la gente
habla pensaste en adaptar uno de tus
libros al teatro o al cine o incluso
escribir directamente una obra de teatro
yo he visto que ya eres con guionista de
una película que se llama Jesús López
Cómo te fue este trabajo muy diferente
me imagino que escribir sí
escribiese o colabore en el guion con el
director que es
difícil para mí porque el cine claro la
escritura de cine es bien diferente a
escribir novelas es mucho más tiene más
reglas y más normas y Pero bueno lo
pudimos llevar adelante por suerte y la
película quedó preciosa Me gustó mucho y
recibió muchos premios además
si los libros
ladrilleros y el viento carraza si se
adaptaron al cine todavía las películas
no están listas pero
el viento Carranza ya terminó el rodaje
y supuestamente se va a estrenar este
año o el año próximo yo no colabore en
las adaptaciones pero sí que los libros
se han llevado bueno se están llevando
al cine y del viento carraza en creo que
hubo también una ópera
O sea no no fue llevado al teatro pero
sí se adaptó el ritmo de las palabras
escritas eso pasó a la música
y tú me estoy preguntando eso ahora
cuando estás escribiendo escuchas una
música en particular o escuchas cosas es
que de verdad se siente que hay mucho
sonido Hay mucho ruido hay muchas sí me
pasa de corregir
leyendo en voz alta Entonces como Bueno
tengo ya el oído también afinado para
para eso pero y también hay como cierta
música interna en la cabeza mientras
estoy escribiendo Pero después la
corrección para corregir lo leo en voz
alta y incluso cuando le escribí a este
libro mi fantasía era que los lectores
bueno tendría que el libro se publicara
los lectores también pudieran leerla en
voz alta Bueno un consejo para los
lectores sí
buen consejo y salva para terminar yo
quería hablar de tu librería virtual que
se llama salvaje Federal nos puedes
contar un poquito más sobre este
proyecto Cómo nació y si está accesible
a todo el continente latinoamericano Sí
bueno tiene un poco que ver con lo que
hablábamos al principio de la de la
centralidad Y de lo difícil que es que
la
y las ediciones de las provincias
circulan fuera de sus regiones Entonces
armamos esta librería con unas amigas
que está como especializada en esa
literatura literatura Argentina pero
saliendo un poco de Buenos Aires también
ahora es una también es Física Pero lo
interesante de que sea una librería
virtual Es que de cualquier parte del
país pueden comprar los libros y y bueno
y acceder a esos autores que si no es
muy difícil encontrar en las librerías
incluso Navegar porque yo vi que es un
poquito un mapa de una cierta forma
puedes entrar y literal escoger como Sí
porque la O sea no sí no está no está
dividida
en
géneros sino en regiones y bueno
entonces
yo entras a la a la al estante fluvial y
ahí te encontrás literatura de cuatro
provincias que están más integradas a
las zonas de Río y de agua y bueno Y así
con cada una
podés Investigar un poco autores de cada
lugar bueno Muchas gracias salud y
gracias a ustedes por su confianza sigan
con nosotros hay más culturas 24 y tras
24 punto com